everyone
[Music]
we're a bit late but i think everybody's
here now
welcome to this morning's meeting of the
paper planning committee i'm going to
ask the government's officer to read out
the domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations thank you claire
thank you chair
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you're attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to asylum
we will be using the e-boating for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
good members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium if you are in
the atrium at the time of alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not the lifts do not re-enter
the building until told it's safe to do
so
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair thank you claire
that's claire
philpott our government's officer also
pleasant today is the chief planning
officer phil isbo
area planning manager mark russell
and our legal advisor ian duprey
morning and the case officers today are
samantha summers
and jamie martin edwards
thank you
moving on
okay here we go
apologies for absence and substitutions
please claire
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor suez um
councillor margaret mabry
and we have no substitutions thank you
declarations of interest
non-received non-received thank you
moving on confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting held on the 8th on the 30th
of march you've all had a copy i hope
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these meetings
of these minutes sorry
nope fine in that case could i have a
pros of
councillor osborne thank you secondly
council jameson
i'm now get the government's officer
conduct the electronic votes
thank you chair members that voted to
know in progress
council beer
thank you
thank you chair that's
seven votes for and one extension thank
you
and sir approved
um
i will sign them later
receive notification and petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
unreceived
site inspections
sam i believe you're going to make a
site inspection request
thank you chair and good morning members
this committee site inspection request
comes directly from the chief planning
officer
the application is for the conversion
repair and extension of existing farm
buildings to form five dwellings
erection of the garage demolition of
buildings provision of new vehicular
access and associated landscaping at
irwiton hall farm yard
members may remember that councillor
davis requested a site inspection
previously and members voted against the
site visit
since that time further information has
been received and consultations have
taken place
it is on that basis that the chief
planning officer
urges members to reconsider their
decision not to visit the site
the chief planning officer would like
members to visit the site in
the chief planning officer would like
members to visit the site in order to
fully understand the location of the
application site and its context within
the historical setting of a grade one
listed gatehouse and grade two star
listed hall
this plan shows the relationship of the
site to the listed buildings
the site is marked with the yellow
square
the grade one listed gatehouse is marked
with the red star
and the grade 2 star listed
hall is marked with the orange star
the buildings to be converted are
towards the front of the site
with the large barn to be demolished
sorry could i have my pointer
sorry a technical hit
quick question for the officer i can see
two large barns which one is in there
yeah i'm just trying to get my pointer
up and then i'll be able to show you
okay
that would help
okay so we have this large barn here
that would be staying
this large barn here would be removed
and the buildings to the front of the
site
are the ones to be uh converted into
dwellings
uh this shows in a bit more detail
what's proposed so that very large barn
at the back of the site is to be
retained
and the barn the large barn that you saw
in this area here to be demolished
these are the buildings to be converted
and extended
to form the five dwellings
this plan shows the proposed layout
uh during a site inspections
members will also have the opportunity
to see the location of the proposed
access point which is across this
paddock here
and what the effects might be on the
area of outstanding natural beauty
the owners of erwiton hall which is the
grade 2 star listed building just here
have agreed that members can go on to
their property to view
the site
from from their house
and to see the context of the site
with the grade 1 listed gatehouse but
also the grade 2 style listed building
um
here are some photographs um
and on the left hand side you'll see
where the photograph is taken from
just to give you a bit of context
the whole of the site is
contained within a red brick wall
there's some breaks in it but not very
many so it's it's an intact farmyard
area
this one is just taken uh
from this location here just looking at
those front buildings and wall
and these are some of the buildings that
would be
converted
this is the grade one listed gatehouse
with the farmyard behind
again looking in the other direction so
you can see how close
these farm buildings are to that grade
one listed
gatehouse there
this is taken from the driveway of
irwiton hall looking back towards some
of the buildings that are to be retained
and extended
again
looking from oweton hall back into the
site
as you can see that
very strong brick wall that surrounds
the site is mainly still intact
just moving a bit further around the
site
another one of the barns that would be
converted
this is taken
from the back of the site so that's the
brick wall that forms a boundary
and this large building is the one that
is to be retained so from that area you
can't see any of the buildings at the
front of the site
this is going from the other direction
on the other side from the paddock area
the brick wall has actually failed just
here
i believe that the application also
involves rebuilding of that brig wall to
put back
the wall and the boundary
apart from the section that would be the
breakthrough for the access
this metal barn here is the one to be
demolished the one at the front is one
of the ones that is to be converted
this is looking at the access point
through to the site so this is the
building to be demolished
just here you can see one of
the buildings to be retained and that
very large dutch barn that will also be
retained is in this area here
again that's the large dutch barn to be
retained
that you could see from the garden of
erwinton hall
some of the brick wall
this is looking towards the back of the
site towards
erwitten hall in the background here
this is looking from the access point
across the paddock where the access
drive would cut across here
and that's it thank you
the lights come on i'll be able to see
you
councillor beer
thank you mr chairman i i couldn't quite
hear but did you say we'd already had a
request for a site inspection
um from councillor davis and that was
turned down
i can't remember the reasoning and why
what is different now between that
request
and the request now of the treat plan
and officer who wants us to go on it
and why is it taking all this time
with the difference why didn't we know
this at the last when the original one
was put forward
i'll get the chief playing i'll answer
that for you
thank you
uh thank you chairman um the uh at the
time of the previous request we
obviously hadn't received the advice uh
in the detail that we have now and the
application has actually changed from
that to uh now
the application um has received quite a
lot of comment if you look on the
website there's over 50 comments have
been received from locally interested
parties which itself is of no measure of
anything other than interest
but we are
in that sensitive value in the
relationship
the heritage comments that we have
are not completely consistent and to
that extent i think it's useful for
members to understand the relationship
between buildings and take a view for
themselves when coming to their own
decision
we as officers have got to make a
recommendation that will kind of way
way up what recommendation to put to you
but there is quite a lot of interest in
the heritage angle here and from my
point of view it's sensible for members
to go on site to view those elements for
themselves including the access
and the relationship of the various
elements of the barn group to the
adjacent listed buildings thank you
quickly come back on that
yes i accept and understand all that i
just think it might have been more
helpful at the time
to councillor davis who put this forward
that this perhaps information or
discussion
should have been head because
that would have saved
us doing it twice and i do no i do think
it's a valid point mr chairman the
counsellor came forward with a request
and we said no progress and uh
you know there's no change their mind
i'm sorry councillor davis
to speak
and he will
give you the true version or the right
version of what you were suggesting any
more questions
counselor hidden for the officer yeah
just a quick one for samantha the access
point new access point for the new
development for the houses and
the barn conversions seems to
[Music]
completely cut off along with the
development seems to completely cut off
the to be retained dutch barn how is
access supposed to be
gained to that building or do they have
to go through the gardens of the houses
that are going to be built
um i'm not too sure the relationship of
the existing farm yard and how that will
be
accessed currently it is access through
between
some of the farm buildings
at the front
that wasn't actually a suitable access
visibility is very very poor in that
location so they have
suggested
cutting across that paddock my
understanding is that rose would be able
to clarify this uh during her
presentation to committee is that all of
the traffic will be going
uh through that new access point not
between the existing buildings as is the
situation at the moment
mr chairman if you put if
sir amanda can put up the
the proposed development
um plan over overview
you can see what i'm i'm getting at
that
new road comes in fair enough if it's
needed because of visibility etc then
that's a logical way to do it but as you
can see it creates a
east west
or west east whatever it is um
entrance way there with some buildings
but leaves the re to be retained
building almost sort of cut off from any
point of access whereas the existing
layout is linked into the main
farm yard
which one would expect yes i completely
understand what you're saying and i
think this is one of the reasons that
the chief planning officer would like
members to go out on site and
understand the relationship of how
everything's going to work there will be
more detailed plans available i'm sure
at the time of the site visit so that
you can clearly see
and i will um ask that question to rose
and perhaps she could clarify that if a
site visit takes place
chief planning options like to make a
comment
just to add to what sam has told you um
the uh
area of the pole barn that you just see
described there that you're referring
referencing
was previously the
application for two dwellings on that
site that's now been emitted as part of
this and there you now have a
relationship which includes i believe uh
potentially equestrian use which has
already been going on on the site
in relation to the adjacent um
conversions
and access as far as i understand it and
i may have that we will check this and
advise on the day
it is shared the present access through
the farm yard is
i think from all intents purposes
not a desirable
access in terms of visibility onto the
main road and i think all of these
elements there is some controversy as
you'll see from the papers in due course
about positioning of the access and its
relationship
all of those elements do require careful
consideration chairman so
um i think the circumstances that that
is a changed circumstance from the
position when the application was put to
you for a site visit previously and
albeit we have fewer dwellings
we have a more complicated proposal in
some senses thank you
any more questions for the officer
okay
mclaren um do we get an opportunity to
contribute to the debate after
yeah yeah i'm gonna get yeah
if all the councils have finished asking
questions i'll get councillor davis as
the ward member to make his comments
hope he won't take too long and and then
we can move into some sort of debate
chancellor davis
thank you chair um and thank you for
allowing me to speak on this and also i
want to say thank you to sam for a very
good presentation which hopefully
planning committee members will have
glee more from from that presentation
than the previous one and the reason why
i've asked it to come back
after discussing it with uh phillis bell
chief planning officer is because i felt
that the last time you weren't really
given enough information to make
perhaps the correct decision not saying
it was wrong last time it was just
probably not
the way it should be this is a very
controversial and very complex
application and it's been rumbling on
for quite some years previous
applications have been turned down i'm
not here to extol the merits of the uh
either a refusal or or any sort of
determination but just to implore you to
come out you need to see for yourselves
just what all this is about the
topography the location of the uh the
proposal uh close to a grade two listed
gatehouse which is less than a football
field away uh to the grade once grade
two star
listed house
um how that overlooks the gardens and
how the the development will dominate uh
over that there's also the importance of
it being in the aomb you need to
literally walk the land to see uh
you know how that plays out in terms of
um the street itself the the small
lanes that go through earth and i know
some of you will already be aware of it
but in relation to this development i
think it's important that you see that
councilor hinton points out about the
entrance it's really important that you
see that in reality in situ how it
relates
so i won't go on i just like to
underline the importance of please come
out and do a site visit
thank you
thank you councillor davis
um
any questions council davis
you prepared to take no okay fine would
anybody like to comment
oh allison would you like to start
jessa i'd like to propose that we um go
for this site visit
um thank you council for a second to do
it
any more comments mary you were keen
yes chair well when it came last time i
actually supported a site inspection
visit
i think this committee has got to be
consistent in its application of the
rules
two weeks ago we had a great debate
about
heritage
at term
site inspection we did
this erwiton hall is known to me it's
neighboring to my patch
and i think members need to see
it's his need to know its history and
how it relates to the nation and i think
it's important that they make a good
decision if they visit it so i'm
supporting the inspection visit thank
you
thank you mary
any more comments
counselor osbourne
thank you mr chairman i absolutely agree
with the
proposal and secondary on this and
obviously with the overview that uh
councillor davis has given i think this
is a an opportunity to look at something
which is quite a complicated setup and
i'd prefer to see these site thank you
council
any more comments
if not i'll ask the governance officer
to organize a vote
thank you claire
thank you chair
members that boat is now in progress
council a bit
thank you
um
thank you members chair that's seven
votes four and one against so that's
carried that's current thank you
and
i think we're going to try to arrange
this for next week fourth of may
4th of may
thank you
thank you very much
moving on to the planning application
for us today dc 20 03116 land to the
east of sudbury road cockfield ferris
and edmonds
um
councilman is not with us
in that case i will now invite the case
officer
sorry jamie i'm rushing you
i've now got the case off so once he's
all up and running to introduce the
application
[Applause]
thank you chair
good morning members good morning
members of public
this application is on land east side of
sudbury road cockfield
erection of a new workshop building with
existing access to the site from the
a1141 which will be upgraded
so a bit of application context to start
with this application was presented
before committee on the 10th of march
2021
the application was granted as per
officer's recommendation at the time
on the 8th of july
2021 the decision was quashed for a
judicial review process
the challenge of the decision was to
claim that there was a misinterpretation
of the application of policies
from the development plan and in
particular cs2 cs11 and em20
so this application has been brought
before committee members today
as a fresh
assessment
so give some site context further
red outline there just shows the area of
weber
we're situated
just north of cross green in cockfield
and again to give some more context in
regards to the towns urban areas and
core villages that we perhaps see this
type of application directed to
this gives an indication of how far away
they are so 16 kilometers away from
stone market 26 kilometers away from
ipswich 18 kilometers away from hadley
seven kilometers away from uh lavanam
13 kilometers away from sudbury 10
kilometers away from long melford and
eight kilometers away from
barristan edmonds
just zooming in a little bit further um
i'm not sure on this you can see it
quite clearly but i'll start off by
indicating where the site is indicated
in the hatched area it's got an orange
outline in this map
there's a green
box here and a green box here these
indicated two buildings which first
grade
limited which the applicants currently
residing they rent these properties
and work out of there's a blue
building here as well it's marked as
blue it's not blue in real life but um
this indicates a second building that is
rented by a different um business and
together they make up ivy house which is
a small cluster of commercial buildings
i've also indicated here in the red box
is crossways which is a residential
building
and it's outlined cartilage in a red
outline there
it's also key to note that we have a
haulage business just to the south
and we also have a cluster of farm
buildings here and some residential
buildings
darling's here and there's a residential
bungalow just in here as well
so this is just showing the red outline
plan it was shown on orange on the
previous map and we've also got the blue
outline which shows uh land also in the
applicant's ownership so there's this
land in between
the residential building and crossways
and the existing buildings commercial
buildings
that is not to be developed as part of
this application you'll see later on on
the landscape plans that there is some
buffering that's going to be proposed in
these areas
again just some context
if i just bring up some notes with me
thank you so we have the a134
traveling along here
and what i've indicated here is a
constraints map
the shaded buildings are listed
buildings and this is a conservation
area of cross green cockfield
the site is on this side here
so sites indicated with a star here
and
that is the settlement boundary
of the hinterland village of cockfield
cross green i'll show on the next slide
that actually cockfield is made up of
multiple hinterlands or multiple sets
settlements that make the hinterland
village of cockfield as a total
that distance between the two is
approximately 420 425 meters
it's separated by agricultural fields
and just in this area here we can see
lakes and ponds
associated with the farmstead down here
so these are the settlements that make
up cockfield we've got cross green here
the site is indicated here
we also have
great green
on this side
and we have crowbrook down this side
and windsor green here so collectively
they make up cockfield area
so just moving into some of the plans
this is a topographical survey
the site is fairly flat
it's on slightly lower ever so slightly
lower land than the the main road that
runs along its western boundary
so the development itself is a
purpose-built
workshop or commercial building
it's got a lean 2 extension on this side
the access is currently existing but
this will be improved as part of the
proposal and widened
you can see a large area of tarmac
and we can see storage area on the side
here as well
we also see from photographs that i'll
show on screen shortly that we've got
some overhead lines these are proposed
as part of a uk power networks
application
to be put underground
so the building itself
let's make sure we get the measurements
correct on this
we're looking at external dimensions
54.9 meters in length
25 meters wide
and a ridge height of 10 meters
and an eaves height of
8.82 meters
additionally the lean 2 element which is
shown on this side here
the dimensions are 24.8 meters in length
and 8 meters wide with an eaves height
of 7.6 meters
this makes up the proposed workshop and
office building which have a combined
gross internal floor space of 1607
metres squared
we've got the main area of the workshop
in the center
we've got cafeteria
canteen
office
elements office rooms and toilets
and then the lean 2 element which is
here
is the paint shop
cross section of the building important
to see because what we've got is a
purpose-built crane inside which will
help with the
moving of large
fabricated objects
apologies this doesn't show very clearly
on on this slide on the screen big
screen but this is the existing access
and it shows the visibility displays
and again visibility space on this side
we're going to have two trees removed to
be able to
cater for the improved access we've got
one tree here that's going to be removed
and there's another one approximately
here in the visibility display that will
be removed
so this is just showing the drainage
design um
can't quite see very clearly there but
under the tarmac we have a soak away
there that will be for the building
itself
and then we have a secondary soak away
located just to the north still within
the red line plan and that will act as
the soak away for all of the hard
surfacing within the site itself
foul water drainage comes out of the
building and again it's not very clear
on on what you can see on screen
apologies but if you just follow my
cursor it goes north of the fire water
drainage
and in essence comes across here
and into a ditch here that the
applicants have permission to drain
into
so again we can see the
overhead wires here that will be put
underground
and then what we can also see here and i
do zoom in on the next slide to make it
a little bit more clear but we've got
decent amount of uh landscaping in this
position here
and also within the buffer which is the
blue
blue line area outside of the
red line to the north which increases
the buffer with the residential dwelling
we've also got some planting along this
side here
so then just to zoom in again tree
planting on this corner
and tree planting along this side
and then this is a 10 meter buffer in
total that the applicants are now
proposing which wasn't before members on
the first application
to increase the buffer with the
residential building to the north
it's probably also important to note
that the existing access or existing
driveway should we say goes all the way
up to this edge here there are gates
currently which are indicated on here
that go into the existing commercial
area
um
so just some photographs this is a
mixture of photographs that you'd seen
the first time around and some new
up-to-date photographs so this is the
exact access as existing this will be
widened
signs removed this is the particular
tree that's going to be removed as part
of the process
you'll also note up here that i've just
put some arrows of where they're
actually photographs have been taken
from so this is looking through
the visibility displays my understanding
from cross-reference in the plans and
being on site is these this is the tree
that's going to be removed out of for
the visibility displays
there's no other trees to be removed
so just standing inside the site in this
direction and looking
in a kind of north west area we can see
the existing
conifer trees
that are part of the buffer for the
crossways residential building and we
can just see the tops of the existing
commercial buildings that first grade
are currently in
the concrete pad or driveway which runs
along that eastern boundary is existing
and we can see obviously the
parcel of land itself
is mowed grassland
so just standing from the opposite end
and looking down this is a more recent
photo that was taken
looking at the concrete pad we can just
see that tree there that's going to be
coming out
and just looking
in a westerly direction we can see the
overhead lines that are proposed to go
underground
so just jumping up onto
this area here we can see the
neighboring tenants of the ivy house
site
and then just looking down the a143
and then just opposite the current
access to you can see the office block
that is
rented by first grade here and the park
car parking and we can also see here
these photos stitched together the
access into crossways
and we can just about see the top of the
house of crossways in there
so similar position but just looking in
a southerly direction
and we start to see the site here
again you can see roughly where that
photograph's been taken from
and then just going down to the t
junction area and we can see the site
in its entirety grass mode area we can
see the buffer area across with the
residential drilling crossways
the existing axis
that they would now be using is further
down this road here
and this is where we'll see the planting
come on to the corner that i showed you
on the landscape plan previously
haulage company which is
just on the other side of the junction
and if i just flick back actually you
can just about see the farm buildings as
well on the opposite side of the road
that located here
a bit more scope of the existing haulage
business that's there
and again the farm buildings on the
opposite side
so the recommendation in this instance
is that we see that this site is
disconnected from
existing settlements it's classified as
countryside and therefore contrary to
cs2 and cs11 our recommendation is
refusal on this instance
thank you chair
thank you very much jamie
any questions
from the members
come on counselor
could i just ask you
um
i say the highways comments but what
you've just said about the road you
don't say much about the actual a134
road and the junction there
which is definitely in need of some
considerable improvements because the
road is narrow there's no middle lane
for turn and right if you're coming from
the subway road
was there any comments of that at all
anywhere other than just what i've read
in the highways response
this response that's great
thank you
any other questions
counselor busby do you go back to slide
four please
there you go sorry about that that's
right that's my fault um
it's in the countryside but i mean it's
fairly central to most of them the towns
in our area one would argue that it's
actually
quite a good location for a business
wouldn't you think
i think if we look at the development
plan as a whole
cs2 says
not in the countryside subject to
and cs11 says has to be well related so
that's what we're making the judgment on
particularly in the evidence of a jr
recently
where we perhaps looked at it in the way
that you were saying that
isn't that well related
i mean it's
central to everybody everywhere
i think just
how you interpret
some of the words in the panning
policies
i think that we need to be thinking
about where employees are coming from
where future employees are coming from
where business is coming from
is that a sustainable location
those policies that we have in the
development plan are looking to direct
this type of development towards our
urban areas to our core villages which
this is not
any other question question council
change that you have a question
yeah thanks
uh
in your your report on paragraph
3.42 you say that the applicant could
have looked at
options at gateway 14 in lady lane
or sudbury
and
do we know if there's definitely land or
buildings on any of those sites that
would have been
perfect for this
applicant
i think it's key to understand that this
is a purpose-built building
and but what i would also add is that
there's a substantial amount of um land
that's been approved recently for
commercial areas
and there's no reason why that land
can't come forward and be changed
slightly to to make a purpose built
something on it if there's approvals
already on there um but in our eyes that
that land that we've approved at gateway
14 sudbury hadley lady lane for example
we've got allocated land that's still
redundant um
there's no reason why this building
couldn't go on any of those sites so
there is
plots and areas in those
business sites that would have been
suitable in your opinion
in my opinion there's there's land
available for this type of this type of
building um and we would be more than
happy to look at a subsequent
application should a tailor-made package
for that particular piece of land that
has allocations on
okay thanks
thank you any more questions for the
officer
counselor buzzfeed i'm just picking up
on that point but
those places that we've we've referred
to there aren't
close to
this site
and the
the business is already on this side
and they're presumably convenient for
its employees to go there saying it's
quite easy to say oh yeah you can go to
gateway 14 or
the sugar
british sugar
you know whatever yeah
this is where the business is
of course so the business isn't on this
site this is an undeveloped land the
business is on historical farmstead
that's been converted in in the past
that's kind of gone through that organic
process
um in terms of uh
going on to apologies i forgot the first
part of the question council apologies
the statement well it's
it's saying that these other places are
available that's right
i'm with you now and the employees work
where they were
i think we need to be careful with that
there's a risk that needs to be
evaluated does that give an opportunity
for every single rural business
within our district to to say exactly
the same thing and just develop the
greenfield site next door to them that's
a precedent that we might be standing by
taking that kind of approach
chief burning officer which is the
commons
thank you yes i mean it's always a
difficult one where you've got rural
businesses that have grown and have
outgrown their location essence we've
faced this and have faced this over many
years
and that's where your policies look to
direct employment in a particular way
and we as officers have gone through cs
cs2 cs11
and
look to explore that in detail with the
applicant they they have answered that
you know the committee is here to make
its judgment on the application and
the important point from the planning
authority's perspective is consistency
of decision making thank you chairman
thank you
council mclaren
i i'm really confused actually because
it's only 15 months
that uh in this committee we've been
advised to support the application
why
are we in the position we're in today
where we're looking at that decision
that was made or the other
recommendation it was made by officers
chairman so
the previous committee hearing um
looked at the application without
scrutinizing cs2 cs11 issues
those policies apply to this development
as they do to residential
and
we accepted that that was a defect in
our reasoning
and uh that's why we bring the
application back to you with further
information
our assessment and the applica and the
applicant's position on those policies
so yes it was presented to you
previously um and
that was the subject of a third party uh
challenge uh in the courts
so that's why it's back here
thank you chair yeah i have a question i
think it probably is more best directed
to the chief planning officer than the
the officer of no offense intended um
because it concerns the policy issues
that the jr have highlighted
so they've um
the jr recommend that says that we're in
conflict with cs2
cs11 and um
em
i forget which em but you know the one
it's in the papers but i also note in
paris 3.5
that um
that case makes it clear that most
important policies should be viewed
together
and an overall judgment made whether the
policies as a whole are out of date so
my question is
are the policies referred to cs2 cs11
ems etc are they to be considered out of
date since we're developing a new joint
local plan how much weight can we give
to this court ruling as compared to the
jr
i just feel like seeking for guidance on
where we focus
thank you chairman so i will try and
shed some light on that
um
the basket of policies idea is not new
effectively if you have any basket of
policies on any application it will
point in lots of different directions
and you will not almost certainly you
will never fully comply with every
policy so you have to take a view in the
round and up to datedness under the nppf
is compliance and consistency with the
nppf
so
our view in advising you and having uh
rehearsed cs11 and cs2 in front of
various inspectors in the past
we're comfortable that that is quotes up
to date for the purposes of your
decision making
so it those policies are up to date
they're not the only policies and don't
forget the way that the courts will
approach a problem is to say that the
courts interpret policy decision makers
weigh the policy and when you look at
the nppf that says many things about
economic prosperity and development
which arguably you might say on the fact
you weigh differently to the development
plan
the starting point for any decision a
court will tell you is the development
plan and you should make your decision
in accordance with it unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
the nppf is one of many considerations
and as i'm sure the applicant and his
agent would tell you
that you know there are policies in the
nppf which attract attached significant
weight to economic growth
but we have to take a kind of
a consistent view as decision makers and
if there is a departure here
we need to be able to identify why that
departure should be made and give
reasons it does not stop the committee
from making a departure you are not hide
bound to follow the policy
but the public expect you normally to
follow it because that's your policy as
a council does that in any way help chan
i'll ask clemson
i think it's it's important to get this
out so early on because it's going to be
the central point we're going to be
considering you're right
pastor jameson
look yeah just sort of following on from
that
is the way we
assess the um policies we're talking
about depending on whether we think this
is a
judge this is a relocation or an
expansion do the policies determine
differently
so if i if i take that one policy m20 is
from your local plan and a saved policy
doesn't exist as in a similar format in
the nppf so you could question whether
that is completely up to date for its
com
consistency or alignment with the nppf
cs2 and cs11 are called strategy
policies they have they do not talk
about relocation and realignment
they talk about
proximity to built up area boundaries
and their test effectively is that
sustainable development should be
located on the periphery of
uh
the settlements that you have that's
that's how cs11 and cs15 look to start
their process they're not concerned with
relocation
and you might say that
that is perhaps
a distracting argument it almost
it this is a new site whether whether it
is an extension or a relocation the
facts are this is a new building on a
new piece of ground that does not have a
a planning permission for this use
chairman
thank you
any more questions
for the officer
you can always come back to the chief
planning officer in the debate
no
thank you very much jamie
i will
now invite
the representative of the local parish
council ian levitt if you would like to
address the committee you have
three minutes
ladies and gentlemen good morning thank
you for the opportunity to read out a
statement on behalf of the council
cockfield parish council remains firm in
its position of strongly objecting to
the application for this factory
development
since the outset of this lengthy
consultation cockfield parish council
has continued to raise its concerns as
to the magnitude of the proposals and
the subsequent impact the operation
would have on the locality enabling
immunity
these matters are being communicated in
a number of formal consultation
responses these have all remained
consistent in objections during the
period
similar concerns have also been raised
by immediately local and more distant
residents
equally other consultees have expressed
their reservations on aspects of the
scheme
in attempts to mitigate the effects that
the site would have on the residents and
surroundings the applicant has continued
to provide some reasoning supplemental
information and only subtle variations
to his position
however the overall design and concept
has not significantly changed
and the scheme still represents an
unacceptable imposition on the community
the parish council reiterates that at
this time he sees no significant and
only peripheral attempts to address its
key concerns which are
the overall building mass scale and
design are too substantive for the
location
light spill and light pollution to the
surrounding area
the noise impact of working operations
from both the actual workshop and those
activities within the service yard area
the potential for 24x7 working hours
bringing associated disruption and
nuisance
apartment on restricted delivery hours
together with associated hg hgv
movements leading to further intrusion
concerns as to whether the applicant can
continue his business activities in a
similar manner given that he currently
enjoys an unregulated environment at his
nearby premises
the overall visual impact and limited
extent of landscaping screening equally
the time for any new planting to be
effective
the potential risk for the undeveloped
portion of the overall site coming under
further development if a precedent is
set in allowing the initial factory to
go ahead
the parish council sees the growth of
this metal fabrication industrial
enterprise completely inappropriate for
the location
if there is any desire to develop the
site this is not the solution
a far more suitable and less intrusive
light commercial employment opportunity
or residential use may well counter and
some support
not this factory and its present form
chair thank you
thank you
any questions for the speaker council
beer
um could i ask
whether the parish council has any uh
consultation with the applicant
because you you make a very strong
argument for the size of the building
i personally think it's ugly but um
the master of it
have you
spoken with them or given suggestions of
what might have been acceptable
bear in mind that it is
already there the business
um i cannot recall an instance where the
applicant has attended the parish
council
i am not aware of any
non-parish council meeting discussions
that have taken place
just come back on the other side
follow-on question
if if the
application was for something smaller
and bear in mind we have to deal with
what's in front of us i know that um
would that would have been a more
favorable do you think or
you know would you be prepared to accept
anything or
because this is large and this is mass
and it is only in my opinion i would
perhaps refer to the last sentence i'll
just read it out again
if there is any desire to develop the
site this is not the solution a far more
suitable and less intrusive light
commercial employment opportunity or
residential use may well counter them
some support certainly not this factory
and its present form this chair if i can
just add a point it would be fair to say
i think that obviously i have to come
here and represent the parish council
i think it would be fair to say that
there will be nuances of opinion amongst
parish councillors as to what would or
would not be acceptable
some parish councils will take as a very
high waiting the impact on the resident
in crossroads who is here
some parish councillors would be more
inclined to think about perhaps
employment opportunities in a smaller
item
we are unanimous that the present
proposal is frankly simply too big
thank you councilman
thank you uh i'd like to thank you for
coming on today um you suggest in your
submission and your own statement just
now that you believe this to be a 24 7
operation
i just wonder if you could comment
further on that because i look at the
report and it does state restrictions on
opening times and a restricted number of
times per year that any uh work
would be
possible
restricted to likely no more than 10
occasions per year so that doesn't
square with your suggestion of a 24 7
operation
my understanding of the parish council
discussions is that we accept what is
being written in the original submission
which did talk about 24 7 i believe
there have been changes it would be fair
to say that parish council are skeptical
about what may happen in practice
this is a very dangerous junction if i
may say so which is well known and we're
talking about hgvs here
it's not an easy turning in if any hgv
misses that turning it has to go down to
the conservation area of cross green and
the residents there are obviously
extremely concerned about any potential
for shall we say leakage or movement and
away from my from what might be strictly
permitted
that's mccrory follow up i just wanted
to somebody could tell me if that we
have environmental protection officers
um who do actually look after these
sorts of things i imagine they would be
um on the case if there were to be any
breaches of a planning condition is that
correct
your question is what would happen were
there breaches of
earth
given the skepticism expressed
it would go to our planning enforcement
department and they realized with
environmental health under their own
legislation
any more questions
thank you very much thank you right
moving
on
i understand we do have an objector
would you like to identify yourself sir
and tell us your relationship
hello my name is stephen hopkins i'm a
solicitor and partner of homes and hills
nlp i represent mr mrs hannaford who are
the occupiers of the adjoining site the
residential
dwelling house has been identified in
the photographs thank you you have
three minutes can you please get a bit
closer to the microphone i think
the option is having trouble hearing you
i can do my best
okay
pursuant to section 38 subsection 6 of
the planning and compulsory purchase act
2004 the determination of a planning
application must be made in accordance
with the development plan that's must be
made in accordance with the development
plan unless material considerations
indicate otherwise
the nppf reflects this and makes it
clear that the development plan is the
starting point for decision making
this emphasizes the importance of a
planned led system for good planning
that's what's been impressed upon you by
your officers here
this is a statutory obligation upon this
committee i need to make that clear as
well
the interpretation of policy is a matter
of law that's outlined in tesco and
dundee it's a well-known case the
previous judicial review dealt with the
previous misapplication the previous
misapplication and misinterpretation of
policy you now have a high court
judgment which tells you how you are to
interpret policies cs2 cs11 and em20 and
they've been identified as the key
policies for the determination of this
planning application
your officers report now
interprets these policies correctly and
applies them correctly and recommends
refusal because this
proposal is contrary to policy quite
clearly
your officers report identifies that the
application site is located in an area
defined by the council's development
plan as countryside and outside of the
built-up area boundary the report then
goes on to identify that the current use
of the application site is undeveloped
greenfield capable of being used only
for the purposes of agriculture
horticulture and so on unless planning
permission is granted for a different
use
within the documentation submitted with
this up with the application the
applicant makes it clear and its
intention is to vacate the site it
currently rents and it wishes to
construct a large bespoke premises
elsewhere on this site
let us be clear this is a planning
application for the development of a
large new industrial unit in the open
countryside a new unit on a new virgin
site in the open countryside the
proposal is not for an extension of an
existing site
the policies have been identified
clearly as cs2 cs11 em20 they're the key
ones
policy cs2 deals with the settlement
pattern policy it directs most new
developments sequentially to towns urban
areas then to core villages and then to
hinterland villages after listing those
villages the policy concludes
countryside in the countryside outside
the town and urban areas core in
hinterland village is defined above
development will only be permitted in
exceptional circumstances subject to a
proven justifiable need that is your
policy that you are to apply
no exceptional circumstances no
exceptional need or justifiable need has
been identified and therefore your
professional officer has concluded that
the proposal is contrary to policy cs2
uh yes um it's
to you sir but through our legal
person and you've told us quite a lot of
things that we should and should only
look at and what been directed could i
ask our legal person to explain to me
other members um exactly
what what what he was referring to that
we've got to do this and we've got to do
that i'll i can do it
i
think i think mr hot it is mr hopkins
isn't it um
i think am i am i switched on
can i be heard yes
um
i think
to be precise you said judgment i think
it was a consent order wasn't it i think
i did i wasn't the solicitor of dealt
with the judicial review i think it was
a consent order from my uh but anyway
that doesn't make any any great
difference it the council
accepted itself
would you like to come back on that
please
yes it's a consent order but with any
consent order
um the reasons for the consent order
being entered into have to be clearly
outlined on the order and that those
reasons have to be um approved by the
high court in sealing the order so like
it is a high court order um it's not a
consent
thank you indeed so
yes well mr hopkins has just set out the
plainly unclearly and i i don't no one
can disagree that the law on planning
decision making which is section 38
subsection six
that we we the council must
a decision as to whether there's a grant
or refused plan commission must be made
and must be made in accordance with the
development plan and the experienced
members of this committee know
what the development plan is unless
material considerations indicate
otherwise the nppf is aimed at is not
part of the development plan it's a
material consideration there may be
other factors
referred to by the mppf or
commonly accepted as relevant to
planning decision making which are
material considerations
and the the the officers the council
accepts that there was a mistake in the
chain of reasoning
in its previous recommendation and we we
have now we believe advised you we are
now advising you we're sure correctly as
to the application of the relevant
policies
i don't know if i can go any further
than that
it's my understanding that we are being
asked to re-consider
the original this submission in the
light of the jr
not that um we're being instructed on
how to interpret our policies
um the decision jr decision i haven't
seen obviously well the judicial review
took it back to stage one our decision
was set aside so we're now back to
square one we've now brought you a
report which we believe giving you a
correct advice a recommendation that is
um
soundly uh
resourced but obviously members are at
liberty to consider
um
the um
the massive themselves bring their
decide if they agree with the officer's
recommendation can i come back on the
point
regarding the policy it is it's a key
point for this committee i think i would
i think
in fairness sorry fairness i'll have a
word without leaving
and then we'll see whether he wants to
ask you questions i think if you would
just i don't want this to turn into a
lengthy discussion but in fairness just
i would advise letting mr hopkins make
this point if you'd like to please
if you with your commission chairman
okay could you please make your point
the point is that that this council and
this committee have misapplied these
policies on a number of occasions
previously
and we now have quite a clear um
judgment on a number of occasions now as
to the correct interpretation of policy
cs2 and cs11 and it's not that we're
you're being instructed to do anything
but what you have is a clear
judgment or clear
interpretation of the policy which you
should follow
that's the point we're trying to make
and the officer's report now recognizes
the previous misapplication
and
interprets the policy correctly i think
that's the point to be made thank you
i'm obliged
thank you
any more questions for the objector
no
right moving on
we do have
a supporter of the application
so can you identify yourself and tell us
what your connection is
my name is alan valentine i'm the
owner and founder of first grade
recycling systems
thank you you have three minutes to
address the cancer
committee sorry
at first grade we design and manufacture
screening and sorting systems for
recycling companies to help them
increase their recycling rates reduce
waste going to landfill or incineration
this is an existing growing business in
the environmental sector helping to
achieve important government targets for
recycling
we're experiencing high demand for our
products
we cannot meet at this demand because of
limitations caused by our current
premises
we no longer advertise and we're turning
away new customers we're unable even to
meet the growing demand of our existing
customers we are desperate for larger
more efficient manufacturing space
the office officers report says that
em20 can not be used to support this
application because it says this is a
relocation and not an expansion
this is completely false
we are increasing from six thousand to
fifteen thousand square feet of
manufacturing area
and from twelve to twenty probably more
jobs how can you argue that this is not
expansion
the report says this is relocation
yes we'll be removing from some old
buildings to a new building but we'll be
at the same address and using one of our
existing two entrances
in the eyes of my staff my customers and
my suppliers this is not relocation
for the benefit of local jobs in the
local economy this is not a relocation
our benefit to local businesses and
local community will remain and increase
i cannot understand how this can be
considered as a relocation
i do not believe the planning officer
has properly grasped our requirements
for our manufacturing premises
the recycling plants that you
manufacture are physically very large
one plant can take us four to five
months to build and contain many
components
some of these components are up to four
metres wide and 17 meters long that's 12
feet by 55 feet
we need a large space to manufacture
these large items
space to move them into a paint shop
space to assemble them after painting
and then space outside to store them
while we carry on with the manufacture
of the rest of the plant
then we need space to load them onto a
lorry using the crane before delivering
of the delivery of the complete plant
we need a large manufacturing space with
a large outdoor space and we cannot
afford to compete on price against the
international companies bidding for
warehouses along the a14 corridor as the
officer has suggested
this is why we've not been able to find
suitable president
premises despite looking for over 12
years
this is the exceptional circumstance of
our planning permission as required by
cs2
the objections raised by the public and
the council have been carefully
addressed by the officers report and
found not to give reason for refusal
thank you
any questions for mr newman the
objective another supporter sorry
well camps are owen
hi
i mean
i know you said you you can't afford to
to go to different places but
crying out in delphi the old delphi site
have you ever looked at that the old
delphi site in sudbury
have you ever looked at
that because
what you're putting in the ground
paint
they put oil in the ground you know and
it's to ruin another site
where you could
could put it
somewhere where the underground's
already ruined if you know what i mean
so is that did you ever look at delphi
site was that ever looked at
no no it's yeah
um
it's such a shame because because
crying out for and you've got the space
up there
i don't know whether the new people
would like to sell but
it's just standing there at the moment
i'm not familiar with the side i'm
afraid
yeah i'm not familiar
okay thank you
thank you thank you
thanks um thanks for coming on this
morning i'd just like to ask um the
current
fabrication
operation takes place to the north of
the house on the other side as it were
is that correct yes
so north and east and east sorry it's
okay but it's the existing operation
what happens to that
should permission be granted
and would you be making any mitigating
measures with respect to that i'm
looking at the overall
effect and if we accept the point that
the the two
two entrances make this essentially the
same site
which is obviously the discussion but
what happens to the old fabrication uh
once the work is completed
we currently rent that premises so it'll
go back to the the landlord which is
growing parish engineering uh and
they will either use that themselves or
they'll
it's up to them
you wouldn't be considering operations
then
that's the plan is not due
thank you sorry i'll get the
microphone in the right place
mr valentine can i ask why you've not
had any according to the parish council
you've not had any discussions with the
parish council
during this application
okay
i was originally advised not to not to
go to the paris council i did try to go
to the council meeting in in
earlier this year uh
um i went to one of them which it wasn't
discussed at i think there was an
extraordinary meeting where it was
discussed which which i missed
sorry i can't recall that at all
okay
sorry um
in hindsight
in hindsight it's a wonderful thing yeah
um it's all with applications it is
always good to
discuss with your local parish council
especially in local residents
can you tell me really the reason why
you didn't do that
with hindsight yes i definitely would
i'm very new to the planning process
this is my first ever planning
application and uh the the people doing
the proposal for us uh
they
didn't advise me to go so
can i can i also just follow chairman
did you have pre-planning application
discussions with our planning department
before you
put the application in
yes
okay thank you chair thank you
council
yes he is the applicant
oh i was
did identify himself
at the beginning of his
three minutes so
so will the applicant be speaking in his
own right
so this supporter is also the applicant
this is an app the applicant who is on
obviously support you see
with great respect mr chairman
my fellow councillor put a question
about um whether he'd done something
with the parish council um as the
applicant um but i thought he was
talking as the supporter of this uh i've
got questions for the applicant
uh but not necessarily for the
supporters i just want a rule register
this this gentleman identified himself
quite clearly before he started speaking
as the applicant as as the owner of the
business making the application if you
have questions for him please ask now
well i didn't hear that all that but i
have got questions
uh thank you um
well if i can just follow on from that
um
the
the building um
it really does look ugly to me have you
considered
any way to make it more attractive um
because obviously the parish council
left you in no doubt that they don't
like the mess and the design of it
have you considered
uh perhaps uh adapted that to be more
friendly
and secondly
um
the highways i know that they've
reported here and they don't have a
problem but that particular
junction on the main a131 road is really
quite dangerous
you have ground and facility there have
you at all offered
with the county council to try and
improve improve that
i know they're saying there isn't any
concern but we all know and i use that
road lots of locals there use it
you've said the large vehicles and the
size of some of the equipment they're
going to need very large articulated
lorries
getting in and out of onto that main
road is a serious problem and really
all you're doing is adding to that
you're not offering to help make that
junction any better improvement
and to get a lane in the middle of the
road for that people turn them right
would be
um quite helpful
so
i really want to know what you've done
to try and
solve the problem of the mass and the
ugliness of it and whether you've done
anything or you're just accepting that
highway says it's okay
thank you
with regard to the building i think it's
uh in keeping with the uh buildings to
south hewix hall is similar
shape building and there's some large
agricultural buildings opposite uh
there's going to be quite a bit of
planting around it to to to shield it um
i didn't think it was ugly myself but
that's uh our opinion
um
and with regard to the roads uh we
already use that entrance for the larger
vehicles coming in and out uh there's
gonna be the engine is gonna be upgraded
with
the required visible displays the
highways had no objection and and didn't
suggest that anything else
to us um
thank you yeah
more questions
pastor busby
thank you
can i just clarify it refers in the
report to just one hgv movement on
average per week
is that
correct uh on average yes we did we did
do
a
survey a long time ago
a few
at the beginning of this and uh
noted down every vehicle came in and out
and and that's what it was on average
yes
because we you know if it takes us four
months to build the plant
you know after four months we might have
two or three lorries going out
it's we're not an intensive business
we're
we're uh
just the things we make are quite big so
we need a lot of space
space hungry but not not intensive so
you're saying by expanding almost
doubling in size then
you're only looking at an extra
one hgv vehicle movement per week yeah
okay
and the hours since you say things take
you three four months to produce
why is it that you need to work 24 7 on
occasion and sundays and public holidays
and things like that
we don't uh
we have 24 7 planning permission on on
the buildings we're in now and when we
did this new platform vision we didn't
see and i usually didn't see any reason
to change that so we just put in exactly
the same as what we've got at the moment
we know our working hours now are
eight to eight till five uh monday to
friday uh there are normal working hours
it was in hindsight it was a mistake to
to do that but it's only because that's
what the planning permission is on the
buildings we're in
um so we've changed that now and we have
restricted working hours
um when the discussion came out we were
sticking up working ours we raised the
question sometimes you have a customer
to break down who needs a part made uh
wants you know a breakdown on a
monday afternoon and needs to be up and
running as soon as he can so we we would
someone would work late and get that
done
um
since one year ago there's not been one
occasion when we've actually worked late
for a breakdown so although there's
these conditions in the area that went
were were detailed a year ago in the
last year there's not been one occasion
where we've had to do that
and and if you wanted that taken out i'd
be quite happy to do it because
it's not uh you know we can find
somewhere else to do it
okay thank you
thank you thank you mclaren
thank you chair
mr valentine you
sorry you um
said that you'd had a pre-planning uh
discussion with the planning officer and
in august and we actually approved that
planning application 15 months ago
um had you already
having got the permission
had you already started the work on the
site
no
no
right okay
and and
i was going to ask what would you next
step after this sort of discussion today
uh if it's granted we'll be getting on
as soon as we can i forget there's a
period you've got to wait for anyone to
appeal um and after that we'd be
trying to
to get workers to get to business as
soon as they can thank you thank you
no more councillor busby sorry
would you consider spinning the building
through 90 degrees so that it was
running lengthways alongside the
entranceway
so it was end on to the two residential
properties at either end of it
we've considered all sorts of
orientations um
yes uh i mean we put it where it is
because it's
uh further away from from the the uh the
resident who who objects and so we've
got that buffer zone between us um
and and we thought it was more hidden
where it is behind the existing bigger
trees i think if you put 90 degrees
around it will be uh
more visible from the the a134
but is that an issue
i think i think you've been asked to
cancel me another question
no
any more questions at all
thank you mr valentine
thank you
we have award member presence
cancer
tribe here
the matter has come up i'm afraid we'll
have to pause the meeting
thank you
since for the applicant well i think
we'd almost come to an end of that
hadn't we or other while you've had a
break have you thought of some more
no
thank you again mr vanderhoff
fine
moving on we do have award member
present um
counselorathy you can address the
committees you have five minutes to do
so
thank you
thank you chairman um
yes i'm kind of feeling for you all a
little bit this morning
it's always interesting to hear
lawyers come and speak to you
i sat on this committee for about 25
years i think chaired it for 10
and it always
i always used to sort of wonder whether
perhaps we were just an occupational
hazard to lawyers
but the decision of course is yours
it may well be that lawyers argue about
it afterwards
and i'm not going to go into the
the issues regarding the jr application
on the previous decision of yours
but it all i will say is that it seems
the report and the presentation didn't
make clear
that an approval
would be contrary to our adopted
policies and would have to be properly
justified
um
but i'm speaking this morning as the
local ward member
and also what to add that i've known the
site for well over 40 years um there's a
bit in the report about the history
and i remember it as
waspland drainage and their equipment
being on site and i also remember
subsequent to that when matro
displayed their equipment on the field
in 2013 the parish council conducted a
village survey
which was designed to explore potential
sites both for housing and for
employment and given its previous uses
and its location this site was
considered as a possible site for
employment use
when the application came to you
previously previously the paris council
felt supportive of an employment use
and the employment opportunities that it
would generate
but they had very real concerns if you
remember regarding residential immunity
impacts and you've heard some of those
from the objector this morning
these are covered in section six of your
report and they relate mainly to noise
lighting
odour and hours of operation
they also had reservations regarding the
design and mass of the building and
landscaping which has been mentioned by
the paris council
over the last 12 months and given the
judicial review application
the balance of local opinion seems to
have shifted
and the view now is
still a possible yes to employment use
but not this
proposal and that's because the impacts
of this proposal
cannot be fully and satisfactorily
addressed
now this is a judgment for you
you've got in section six what those
impacts are
and how they could be mitigated
but
whilst that judgment is yours i would
ask you to give special consideration um
for the view expressed by the objector
who
has currently got
the existing operator as a neighbour
we've heard from the applicant that
those buildings will effectively be
on the market for another occupier
there's parish engineering on the
roadside and if this was allowed there
would be this um on
the other side
so i have real sympathies for the
objector um because they would
effectively be surrounded by
employment activity perhaps industrial
activity on three sides with a road on
the fourth side
however
the only way that you can control land
beside you is to own it
and this land has been there and has
been used variously
over the years and one could argue i
suppose that the objector could even
have bought it themselves had they
wished maybe they weren't offered um the
land
so i do have very real sympathies for um
for the objector um and i i have some
sympathy as well for the shifting
position of the parish council because
it was a very very difficult application
for them to look at
you can see from your papers that there
are quite a number of other objectors in
the village
who expressed concerns
and not very many not very many
individuals supporting the application
so it was it was a very difficult
decision um for the parish council and
it their their view has shifted slightly
um since the the previous application
was or the same application was
previously considered by by you so i'd
just like you to take all of those
things into account thank you
council
are you in support of it or uh are you
against it i mean because what you've
said
you're sort of um come down on both
sides i'd just like to understand it a
bit clearly okay well i'm speaking this
morning as the ward member so um i i
have to support the views of the parish
council um they have shifted when i
spoke to you last time
i think the parish council were broadly
supported but they were very concerned
about the impacts
when you considered this last time i
think the view that was taken was that
the
potential harm could be mitigated
against with a raft of conditions i
think at the last committee there was
even mention of the fact that if there
were so many conditions necessary
is it actually unacceptable
on balance i think at the last committee
you decided
that those impacts could be mitigated
against and and voted for approval
thank you council arthur
answer hinton
thank you mr chairman council arthur yes
you mentioned somebody displayed
equipment on that field so how long has
that feel in your opinion being used for
inverted commas
employment stroke industrial purposes as
against agriculture
okay
i think it has been used for
agricultural purposes for grazing um
i i remember it from probably 50 years
ago
when it was used by um i think they were
h wasp and son were a land drainage um
company they owned all of the land i
think from the road down to cross green
including the the pits which were dug
for for sand and gravel
and they used to display equipment they
used to use the land and display
equipment um the the
the most
equipment displayed on on that land was
when matro um displayed a range and i
noticed council of beer nodding um they
displayed a range of equipment probably
on about half of half of the field
i cannot recall ever seeing any
buildings on the land though
i think it was always bare land and used
for display purposes
thank you any more questions counselor
arthur
no
thank you
thank goodness
before we go into debate um i'm told
that the the case officer has a slight
correction to make to one of the maps
was i is that correct
thank you
thank you chair
yes we just noticed when the word
document has been pdf'd in your report
that there's been a slight shift on some
overlay of shapes so on the left hand
side is what you will actually see in
your report
and apologies my battery just died i've
just plugged it on i can't remember
exactly what paragraph it in but it's in
the site description sections
and on the right hand side is what it
should look like
and what this is actually denoting here
is the red line is what it is the red
line plan for this application very
roughly indicatively and then what we're
showing here in green and this is a
historic photo from 1999 i understand of
some storage related to the existing
business at ivy house
that was on that site
there has been no formal application
there's no been no lawful development
certificate as outlined within the
report and
there has also been evidence of gaps
within that use since that photo was
taken
um
as outlined within the report but we
just thought it would be appropriate
just to outline that those shapes have
shifted so
we're not trying to
indicate this plot of land we're trying
to indicate this plot of land it's
literally just shifted when it's been
pdf to to the right for some reason just
thought it'd be important to highlight
that to you
thank you jamie any any questions for
him
that's my call would that um previous
occupation indicate then that it could
be viewed as not being open countryside
having been previously uh developed in
planning terms
i ask because i think it's relevant no
agreed it definitely is relevant but as
set out in the report we look at those
as as evidences as uh
from the applicant as perhaps an ongoing
use of the site but we've concluded
that that site still is considered as
agricultural
answer
mr chairman before you go into debate
as a member of the plan committee
can i ask
that as members will be informed as to
why there was a pause
either now or
after the meeting by email or what have
you it just felt that
quite rightly it is your planning
committee you are the chairman you quite
rightly pause the meeting but i would
like to know as a member as to why it
was paused and the outcome of that and
the reason
whether you wanted to do that publicly
or whether you want to do that
afterwards that's up to you mr chairman
thank you thank you council bear we will
do it at the end let's keep the thread
going of the planning application at
this particular time
and and then and then we'll talk about
it before we end the meeting so it
becomes public knowledge
thank you
okay we're now open
for debate anybody like to kick us off
counselor
well as the first for me haven't done a
case that's been for any form of jr or a
jr order because i don't
think this is so much a judgment as a
technical matter
stating that we can't demonstrate that
we in that decision making that we act
actually
examine cs2 cs11 and the m20 now whether
it's reasonable to suppose that because
it wasn't mentioned
we didn't do it as it rather sort of
assumes that members of a planning
committee have no knowledge of planning
policies without having them spoon fed
to the members but let's put that aside
for the moment so the whole point of
thing is going to revolve around are
examining those policies cs2 cs11 and
em20 in the in the in the round and in
relation to
uh the nppf so i'm looking very very
strongly at section three the principle
of development because i think that's
the only way we can possibly make a
determination on
planning policy issues i think we've
looked at the site in the previous
application mitigating circumstances the
screening the um delivery times and all
the rest of it but i think we first we
have to look at the policies and i look
at cs2 from para 310 and i have to ask
the question are there exceptional
circumstances subject to a proven
justified need
and at the moment um we're clearly
having it's clearly obvious to us that
the exceptional circumstances
um
don't seem to really exist um there are
some i mean exceptional circumstances
could be
the
industrial use but that's described and
the employment is described in cs11
the nppf suggests in para 3.13 that it
doesn't have the same exceptional
circumstances test and as such cs2 has
less weight
so then we're ruling under the nppf
but could i be confident in
granting a permission
with all these questions about proving
exceptional circumstances could i prove
an example under cs 11 that the
additional hinterland village criteria
in 3.27 b
the only one of those additional
hinterland village criteria on page 36
that i can see clearly
that is
is fostered is number four
supporting local services by expanding
employment opportunities
um and i don't i'm not aware that it
compromises any village local plan
but i can't don't think i can
say i would be happy voting
for this permission as it ex as it
stands
um on the basis of those planning
policies and the basis that
i don't think there's a clear enough
case of exceptional exceptionality in
this situation
i just thought i'd throw that in as
that's that's the focus i'm thinking of
thank you case mcgraw for that starting
point
who else would
cancel busby
yes
again it's a tricky one isn't it um
what seems to me is that unfortunately
our our policies
seem to
try and
give us reasons for refusing things
whereas the nppf seems to be more
positive it seems to be
trying to encourage us
to deliver
developments
particularly
industrial employment ones
i mean taking
the whole section six building a strong
competitive economy
planning policies and decisions should
help create the conditions in which
businesses can invest expand and adapt
significant weight should be placed on
the need to support economic growth and
productivity
taking into account both local business
needs and wider opportunities for
development
you know this
this seems to be the mppts seems to be
pushing us
to try and help these businesses and
help the economy grow where our policies
seem to
generate this
well you mustn't do that or we can't do
that we don't want to change that all
that's in the countryside we can't do
this
and it's that's why we have this problem
coming up with a reasonable answer that
we can justify in an argument
i mean
perhaps the
senior planning officer could explain
the contradiction between
paragraph 81 and the nppf and cs2
thank you explain the contradiction um
so as i think i said earlier you will
always find that there is a tension
between policies
and local plan policies are formed over
a number of years you see what happens
with your current joint local plan how
long that takes to prepare so it's not
surprising that local plan policies do
not always necessarily move in sync with
national planning policies the policy in
the nppf that you have there
has been uh in similar words been
running for a number of years as i said
right at the outset it is perfectly
foreseeable that you will have a
development plan policy that says that
you will control development in a
particular area
the question of whether you have
reasonable grounds to say actually we
will depart from that policy and i
i i think that's that's what you're
looking at here is for you
wait the interpretation of policies is
for the courts i'm sure mr duprey will
correct me want to get this wrong the
weight to be attached to policies is for
you as long as you do that reasonably
and the government exhorts you to attach
significant weight to what you do but be
in no doubt you've obviously got
considerable interest in this
application and considerable concern
locally so you do need to you know have
given that careful and thorough thought
you should start with your development
plan policies but they are not a feta on
your behavior you are entitled to depart
from them if you have good reason to do
that question of an exception is not
written into the nppf the nppf says
significant weight
we as planning officers recommend to you
what the policy the development plan
is as your starting point we say that
what you have in considerations take you
to takes you to a conclusion
which is a refusal
as i think councillor arthur wars member
said it's it's your decision as a
committee as long as you're reasonable
with it and the tension
if the facts here and the circumstances
and considerations of this situation
lead you to that conclusion
and you can be reasonable in
demonstrating that that's the committee
trying to suppose if you want to follow
up yeah thanks um
well taking on that on board
were it not for the fact that there are
residential properties within close
proximity to the
proposed site
i would be recommending that we go for
approval
but there are
residential properties
close to the site
and i have a similar
example in chatterjee
where a house is
located alongside
what's become an industrial site where
there are people
repairing
motor cars
there's paint
fumes in the air there's noise there's
lights and it's made
the resident's life an absolute misery
and it's caused all kinds of problems
so as much as i would like
to
suggest that we should approve
in this case
because i do think we should be
encouraging
business and i think it would be an
ideal place
were it not for the neighbours close
proximity and for that reason i can't
really support it
anymore
come to him
it's difficult isn't it because our
local plan
is the
inverted commas blueprint for the
district
but the district varies enormously
virtually
every time you turn a corner it's a bit
different
we have something like 60 percent of our
district that is completely rural it's
either little villages or agricultural
land if not more than that in terms of
percentages
we have something like
eighty percent of our working population
who do not work in the district they
commute out of it every day
uh and here we are um
looking at a potential all right
relatively small increase but it sets
the benchmark for
employment within the district if we're
not going to support and encourage
employment within the district
why on earth do we have economic
policies why on earth do we keep
building houses in the middle of the
countryside
because it says in the hinterland cs
11's the hinterland
extra criteria
supports local services and or creates
or expands employment opportunities
it goes on to um
to talk about does not compromise or the
delivery of of permitted or identified
schemes i don't think this
is a
with any anything compromise any other
identified schemes
yes it's quite a long way from the
inverted commas again functional hearts
of cockfield but there's what three or
four of those
it doesn't actually have one big central
hub it's split up
it is relatively close
to
three large industrial premises
the haulage company the big farm yard on
the opposite side of the road and the
garage facility next door to where his
existing premises are
so it's
yes i agree with
councillor busby that there's a
problem if you like with the fact that
there are
residential homes
close to it
but that doesn't mean to say that we
should say
no to any form of
employment opportunity on this site what
it does say in my opinion is that we
should say yes
but
we want to see
extensive measures put in place to
control
the escape of fumes etc they have a
separate paint shop
which in theory can have a closed air
system around it to keep fumes inside
it needs a big open space for making
these large bits of equipment
that's more difficult to control in
terms of fumes
but
they're not likely to be the sort of
fumes that are going to cause problems
so
[Music]
looking at cs15 and cs11
i think that the the weight
is more on the approval side than it is
on the refusal side
because
it's helping the district
accurate counseling
council high school
thank you mr chairman
yes very difficult situation i i tend to
agree with both of our councillor busby
and councillor hinton
and
i i'm always mindful of the fact of
my days of employment
and the amount of employment we had in
areas that
are
if you like
uh small but
compact and therefore the travelling
that's now going on uh to other areas is
quite large and i would like to have
seen uh employment back in in these
local areas
i'm afraid um
my view is that em 20
which which is developed for employment
and manufacturing
and
etc
does not
out outweigh the cs2 cs11 and also the
the residential housing around it so
it's a very difficult one for me however
i i must say that um
it would be very difficult for me to
support something that
i want
and i'd like to see
and
and manufacturing in that area but
cs2 cl cs11 will
actually not
out well em-20 will not outweigh that
thank you mr chairman
thank you thanks to mclaren
the councillor busby's benefit i'm going
to speak near the microphone he says he
can't hear me
um
twice
today in the previous item and this one
i just feel a bit concerned that members
have been advised to
vote one way
and here again
offices have changed actually their
recommendations to the committee and i
find that
a bit difficult to understand
thank you
thank you
else like to make a comment any other
statement
faster
um
there's a lot in here i think we've all
read it through very carefully we
obviously if many of us remember the
original hearing and the application we
haven't focused as much in this meeting
on um
the site itself the mitigation but we
dealt with that i think quite
extensively at the previous meeting i'm
prepared to propose that we accept the
officer recommendation of refusal and i
ask for a seconder
thank you councilman
do we have a second
thank you we have a proposal in the
second year
are any more comments from anyone
any more discussion questions
before we go to the vote
no in that case i'll ask the area
planning manager to
tell me exactly what we're all voting
for thank you chair um hopefully members
you saw the table papers with the
expanded reasons for refusal
uh the policy issues therein
um are you happy that you've read that
and understanding what the
recommendation is
please speak now if not um so be
reminded that when you're voting now if
you're voting
in the positive
you are going with the officer
recommendation hopefully claire i've
said that
correctly and the recommendation of
course is for refusal so if you're
voting in the positive you're voting for
refusal
thank you
thank you members that vote is now in
progress
council i take
four refusal thank you
hope you've got it right as proposed
thank you members chair that's five
votes for refusal two against and one
abstention that application is refused
thank you thank you very much
that is
it
um
we
i'm
i'll draw the meeting to an official
close and thank you all for your
attendance if those who want to know
what the hiatus was i will
attempt
to tell you with the
legal officer's advice
you